on continue de parler de la crise
sanitaire avec yves buisson
épidémiologistes et président du groupe
kovy 19 de l'académie nationale de
médecine bonjour monsieur buisson et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors la condition préalable
od confinement posé par le président
macron ne sera certainement pas attendre
le 15 décembre
l'exécutif a été trop optimiste en
avançant le chiffre de 5000
contamination par jour n'ont pas trop
optimiste c'était un pari raisonnable
mais malheureusement il semble qu'il ne
pourra pas être atteint
pour différentes raisons et il n'y a pas
que les raisons climatiques
il ya tout de même le comportement des
français qui font que qui fait qu' on
est on n'obtient pas un arrêt de la
transmission du virus dans l'ensemble
des communautés urbaines en particulier
est bon c'est dommage mais ça valait le
coup de fixer un objectif il faudra
fixer d'autres ensuite mais tenir compte
du fait que la mi décembre
nous n'avons pas réussi à atteindre un
niveau de niveau qu'on accepte à de
transmission de ces de cette épidémie
alors on voit bien il est très difficile
de prévoir l'évolution de la courbe de
l'épidémie mais comment anticiper sa
baisse en renforçant les mesures de
prévention mais il n'y a pas 36 moyens
et c'est que comme l'a dit un
intervenant avant moi on connaît les
moyens on sait comment empêcher le virus
de ce sens m encore faut-il les
appliquer
loria et messieurs les mesures des
mesures gouvernementales qui sont plus
ou moins bien ajusté je pense en
particulier lorsqu'on a fait fermer les
les petits commerces considérés comme
non essentiels est ce qu'il représentait
un danger je ne crois pas par contre ce
qui fait ce qui était nécessaire c'est
d'empêcher l'ensemble des bd des
personnes de sortir en même temps dans
les mêmes endroits et réaliser des
concentrations de populations qui
favorise la transmission ça c'est très
difficile à obtenir
il faut jouer sur mance
la persuasion les attestations ça ne
s'est pas révélée efficace puisque
chaque personne pouvait établir autant
de l'attestation qu'elle le souhaitait
dans la même journée donc sortir autant
de fois qu'elle le boulet les contrôles
n'étaient pas suffisants donc
effectivement c'est très difficile
d'organiser cette riposte à l'épidémie
je crois que il faut inlassablement
s'adresser à la responsabilité
individuelle de chacun en disant que
chacun dans son compte par son
comportement peut contribuer à éviter la
transmission
il faut le dire le répéter
inlassablement je crois que c'est le
meilleur moyen parce que les méthodes
coercitives ont leurs limites sauf
peut-être le couvre-feu qui a montré une
certaine efficacité mais qui est une
méthode de deux contraintes important
justement le directeur général de la
santé a lancé hier soir lors de sa
conférence de presse un message de
prudence concernant les fêtes de fin
d'année il craint une hausse des
contaminations à importante
intrafamiliales les faits 5ce billing
comme ça a été observé au canada et aux
états unis vous ne redoutez vous
également bien sûr c'était du nord on
est on est devant deux fêtes proches en
plein hiver au cours desquelles les
personnes vont se retrouver bien sûr
pour faire la fête ce qui est tout à
fait normal pour fêter noël pour fêter
le long de l'an mais c'est des occasions
qui au cours desquelles il est
impossible d'empêcher des comportements
qui seront des comportements ne qui ne
conviennent pas pour limiter la
transmission du virus donc c'est évident
quand on se prépare des effets post fait
qu'ils seront sans doute tout
comparables à ceux de thanksgiving aux
usa et au canada
la france va lancer sa campagne de
vaccination en janvier la stratégie du
gouvernement va être présenté au
parlement la semaine prochaine et on
voit bien que les français sont plutôt
frileux ali
de se faire vacciner alors comment les
convaincre
quelle doit être la communication du
gouvernement de la communication du
gouvernement d'abord doit être clair
compréhensible et continue c'est à dire
qu'au début c'est tout à fait normal que
nos compatriotes soient méfiants sont
tous en leur dit c'est un vaccin
complètement nouveau volet du moins les
premiers vaccins qui vont arriver qu'ils
vont probablement être mis sur le marché
sont des vaccins utilisant la rna
messagers
ce sont des vaccins dont on n'a aucune
expérience donc il est tout à fait
normal il ya un réflexe de méfiance que
tout le monde a et c'est tout à fait
normal
maintenant il faut que les d'abord que
lorsque nous aurons le dossier
scientifique complet des études de phase
iii de freezer biotech et de moderna on
sera nous les médecins nous les
scientifiques en mesure d'expliquer aux
patients qui équivaut à toute la
population qui sera à vacciner quels
sont les avantages et quels sont les
inconvénients
pour l'instant on a encore un peu des
difficultés à leur répondre quand ils
nous demandent docteur ce que je me fais
vacciner ou pas mais on leur billet
coûtait attendons encore un peu de
savoir tout sur ce vaccin et les ses
réticences ont justifié pour l'instant
il ya eu un peu non verbaux sur ces
données qui aimait et un embargo qui est
voulu par les fabricants qui fait qu' on
va se retrouver en très peu de temps
avec des doses de vaccins qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser mais on aura très peu
de temps pour prendre connaissance de
l'ensemble du dossier
et lorsque nous aurons connaissance de
l'ensemble du dossier lorsqu'on aura une
autorisation de mise sur le marché de l'
agence européenne du médicament
lorsque les autorités françaises droit
elle-même statuer sur l'utilisation de
ces vaccins
eh bien nous pourrons y aller vraiment
les yeux fermés parce que il faut faire
confiance à nos autorités ne délivrerons
pas des produits dangereux pour la
vaccination
on va prendre notre temps on va
peut-être pas vaccinés début janvier
sera peut-être alami
l'envié peut être à la fin janvier mais
lorsque le feu vert sera donné à ce
moment là on pourrait aller en toute
confiance
il faudra que la communication
accompagne ces différentes étapes
merci beaucoup professeur yves buisson
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologistes
et président du groupe coville 19 à
l'académie nationale de médecine